merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale et plus particulièrement au
ministre de la jeunesse les jeunes
français qui vivent en dehors de nos
frontières sont une ressource formidable
de talent et de connaissances ils sont
cultivés ouvert d'esprit entrepreneurs
il façonne au jour le jour
l'image de la france et son quand ils
reviennent en france parmi nos plus
brillants éléments plus de 620 mille
jeunes français de moins de 25 ans
vivent à l'étranger
c'est plus que le nombre d'habitants
d'une région comme la vendée où le gard
ces jeunes sont souvent des binationaux
dans certaines zones moyen-orient
afrique du nord plus de 70% des français
qui sont inscrits sur les registres
consulaires possèdent une double
nationalité
c'est une véritable richesse de langue
de pays de culture mais les foires fois
difficile pour la france de garder avec
eux un lien fort ce lien qui nous permet
de dire je suis français renforcer ce
lien et est normalement le rôle de
l'école celui de notre réseau des lycées
français à l'étranger
mais ce n'est pas aujourd'hui le sujet
de ma question je voulais parler d'un
autre moyen de renforcer le lien
d'appartenance avec la france le service
national universel en préparation a pour
ambition de renforcer chez les jeunes le
sentiment d'appartenance à la france
or les jeunes français de l'étranger
n'ont pas été à ma connaissance monsieur
le ministre
particulièrement consulter le mois
dernier lors de la concertation en ligne
les intégrer au service national
universel ou dans un dispositif
similaire est d'autant plus important
depuis l'annnonce il y à quelques
semaines de la suppression des journée
défense et citoyenneté à l'étranger
j'aimerais savoir monsieur le ministre
dans quelle mesure vous avez tenu compte
de la situation de ces jeunes français
et qu'avez vous prévu pour renforcer
leurs liens avec la france
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la sénatrice
votre question en effet extrêmement
importante et je vous en remercie elle
est en résonance avec des travaux que
nous menons actuellement à l'échelle
interministérielle autour de la mise en
oeuvre du service national universel
vous le savez il recouvre plusieurs
enjeux essentiels vous les avez rappelé
la participation et l'engagement de
chaque jeune dans la vie de la nation
la valorisation de la citoyenneté et du
sentiment d'appartenance à la communauté
nationale en se rassemblant autour de
valeurs et en renforçant la cohésion
sociale tout en dynamisant le creuset
républicain l'universalité de ce
dispositif que vous interrogez en
soulevant la question de la
participation des jeunes français de
l'étranger sera en effet un important
défi auquel nous consacrons toute notre
énergie non réflexion s'appuie
actuellement sur les pratiques qui
avaient cours au temps du service
national avant la suspension de ce
dernier l'appel au service national
actif était différée pour les jeunes
français qui résidaient à l'étranger
jusqu'à l'âge de 29 ans et sauf dans
certains territoires européens
si ces jeunes revenaient habiter sur le
territoire national avant d'avoir
atteint 29 ans il était appelé au
service national actif dans les quatre
mois qui suivaient la date de leur
changement de résidence
dans le cas contraire ils étaient
dispensés depuis la mise en place de la
journée défense et citoyenneté
chaque fois postes diplomatiques
consulaires adresse aux administrés âgés
de 16 à 25 ans qui ont été recensés une
convocation écrite leur indiquant la
date de la session à laquelle ils
doivent participer
l'attaché de défense parti pour jdc sous
l'autorité du chef de poste diplomatique
ou consulaire les français établis hors
de france qui n'ont pu participer à une
session de la jdc sont tenues dès lors
qu'ils viennent résider habituellement
sur le territoire national avant l'âge
de 25 ans a participé à une vie des ces
différentes options sont donc possibles
à partir de ces considérations
l'idée étant l' identification préalable
de ces jeunes et les conditions
d'accueil hébergements sécurité des
sites accessibilité accessibilité des
sites aussi dans lesquelles il pourrait
effectuer ce service hors de france pose
de nombreuses questions pratiques
que nous analysons phase par phase cela
ne sera n'est pas arrêtée définitivement
pour le moment mais tout comme au temps
du service militaire et comme cela se
fait aujourd'hui pour les jdc les jeunes
expatriés pourraient être dispensés
d'effectuer le et ses nus dans qu'ils
résident à l'étranger
nous devons ainsi prendre en
considération le contexte particulier de
chacun des territoires concernés
l'absence d'infrastructures le caractère
très dispersé des communautés françaises
les problèmes de sécurité dans certains
pays l'absence de personnel
d'encadrement qui permettent de remplir
les conditions nécessaires et enfin le
caractère non francophones de certains
jeunes et bien sûr le cas particulier
des jeunes binationaux
ceci ne signifie pas qu'ils en seraient
nécessairement exclu nous pouvons aussi
imaginer des hypothèses intermédiaire
les travaux ne sont pas encore
totalement abouti le président de la
république fera en temps voulu les
annonces et nous commencerons par une
première expérimentation en 2019
en tout cas nous étudions dès maintenant
en lien étroit avec le ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
l'ensemble des options envisageables
avant d'arrêter une option définitive
je vous remercie